Let's do a few examples adding
rational expressions.
So let's say we had negative
x squared over x squared
minus 7x plus 6.
And to that I want to
add plus x minus 4.
So to some degree what I want to
do in this first example is
kind of our algebraic long
division or polynomial
division in reverse.
I want to put this x minus
4 in the numerator with x
squared minus 7x plus 6
in the denominator.
The easiest way to do that is
to just literally multiply x
minus 4 times x squared minus
7x plus 6 over x squared
minus 7x plus 6.
I'm not changing the number,
I'm multiplying it by 1.
So if we do that
what do we get?
Well we just have to multiply
this numerator right here, and
we can do that with algebraic
multiplication.
So if we have x squared minus 7x
plus 6 times x minus 4, we
can multiply these two.
6 times negative 4
is negative 24.
Negative 4 times negative
7x is positive 28x.
Negative 4 times x squared
is negative 4x squared.
And if x times 6 is 6x, x times
negative 7x is negative
7x squared.
x times x squared is
x to the third.
So the new numerator is going
to be x to the third minus,
this is 11x squared
plus 34x minus 24.
So now I can rewrite this-- let
me copy and paste this--
this is going to be
equal to that.
Plus I can rewrite this thing
now as being over a
denominator of x squared
minus 7x plus 6.
And our numerator, x minus 4
times this thing over here, we
get this whole thing.
We multiplied them out. x to
the third minus 11x squared
plus 34x minus 24.
And now, since we have the exact
same denominator we can
add these two rational
expressions.
So if you add them, you
literally can just say well we
have the common denominator, so
our common denominator is x
squared minus 7x plus 6.
That was the whole point of
multiplying this expression
over this expression so that
we could get the common
denominator.
And now we just add
the numerator.
So this is going to add to the
x squared side, so you're
still going to have
an x to the third.
And then negative or minus 11x
squared minus another x
squared is minus 12x squared
plus 34x minus 24.
And we are done.
Now we could have checked
whether we could have factored
this, but this just factors
into x minus 6
times x minus 1.
So it really doesn't factor
with the minus 4 in any
meaningful way, so there really
isn't any further
simplification that we can
do for this problem.
Hopefully you enjoyed that.